Hello Freak bitches.
Did you have amateur fights?
Yeah,
I fought in the amateurs and dude,
there was a time when I thought,
you know,
and I think that's why I can,
deal with the fighters and I understand,
you know,
like dealing with the ultimate fighter,
there was a fucking time
in a day when there was,
the only fucking thing I
cared about was boxing.
That's why I literally walked out of that
place because I loved it so much that
that's all I fucking wanted to do.
The problem is you go out
there and you start fucking,
you know that that's what I
wanted to do for a living.
And then the reality starts to
set in and I'll never forget,
I mean I've told this story before,
but I was in the gym one day and
there was this dude who
was a local fighter.
I don't say his name.
You would probably fucking
know him if I said his name.
I guarantee,
you know,
cause he was famous in the Boston area,
like a local guy.
And he came in one day and he was like,
he was in his early thirties.
He was like 31 or 32.
And uh,
he was fucked up.
You know,
he was punchy.
He fucking moping around,
kind of throwing fucked.
And I remember the day
that I looked at him,
I said,
fuck,
what if that happens to me?
And then the minute you fucking
start thinking like that,
you're,
you're not the real deal.
You're not,
no matter how much you think
you want it or you think you do.
It was the day I realized that I wasn't,
and it was fucking like,
wow.
So then you start going,
how the fuck am I going to
make a living doing this?
And me and this dude,
Peter Welsh from Boston started,
uh,
you know,
teaching people how to box
basically businessman and stuff.
Cause the,
the business model wasn't,
if for instance,
like martial arts,
if you want to take a martial arts class,
it's fucking 50 martial arts
studios anywhere in any city,
anywhere in the world.
And it has been since I was a kid,
right?
And he lack of martial arts schools around
your place when you were growing up?
No.
So if you want to buy,
but if you want to box,
you got to go and fight.
You got to go get your
fucking head punched in.
You know what I mean?
You know,
especially,
you know the places in Boston,
you had the Somerville Boxing Club,
you had the fucking place down at the
mcdonough down in South Boston and the
and,
and the,
the Petronellis down in,
uh,
Brockton and,
and places like that.
And you went in and they would fucking,
you'd get your dick knocked loose,
right?
If you came back,
maybe they'd fucking work with you.
Well,
even guys had lights.
You would do that.
Like I got,
I got trained by Joe Lake and that's,
that's what he did with me.
He just stuck me in with guys,
you know that box.
And they all do.
They all do.
Yeah.
They do it quickly too.
Like we're right,
right from the beginning.
Find out how much you enjoyed doing this.
Do you really want to do it?
They a waste of my time
here to exact the right.
I'm going to teach you how to throw
some punches and then we're going to put
your head gear on.
Let me put your fuck of wrestling and
your face and then they can show me what
you got.
The first time they ever went in the box.
They had me do fucking ring circles.
You know what those are right where you
go laterally around the ring fucking
coming in every day they
have to ring circles,
ring circles,
rank circles,
ring circus,
and I was like,
what the fuck?
I paid my dues yet.
Paid my fucking eight bucks.
You know what I mean?
Oh,
I fucked you got mad one day.
I said,
I came here and learn how to fucking box,
man.
I've been running around in circles
for fucking weeks and he's like,
Oh,
you want to learn how to box right?
I fucking like fucking gear you up man.
Love.
Yet they throw you in there and
they beat the fuck outta you.
Fucking dropped me 50
times with body shots.
Punching my fucking head in
the worst of the body shots,
when you first started,
you started taking some body shots from
a guy who knows how to throw him and uh,
you know,
you're fucking lips are bleeding,
your nose is bleeding,
you're fucked up,
you get out,
you're completely morally destroyed.
You know what I mean?
Because boxing is never,
or sparring is never what
guys thinks it's gonna be.
You know,
your watch too many fucking movies.
You go in there and you think you're
going to spar and you get shit kicked out
of you.
But then,
you know,
I went home that night and I remember
laying in bed thinking the whole night,
fuck I got my ass whooped that slug,
this,
that,
and I went back to the gym
the next day and that was it.
Then you start working with you.
Very few people actually want to fight.
They just want to kick someone's ass.
It's true.
They don't understand that.
That kind of kick your ass too.
Like this is not going
to be an even exchange.
And if you're not willing to go to war,
if you're not willing to take like big
shots and be in pain and push through,
you're never going to do this.
This is you.
You,
you have to figure out somewhere along
the line whether or not you willing to
take punishment,
whether it's totally true,
punished by some guys can't.
So that was what our,
what our business was based on.
You know,
Peter,
I,
yeah,
you could come,
you could come into the real gym.
We're real fighters trained and you learn
how to box just like white collar box.
Yeah.
So it was like you learn how to box but
you didn't get your ass kicked every
day.
But some guys,
you know,
start trained for so long and get to
the level where they want to start
sparring.
But you rarely ever have white
collar guys that start sparring.
I want to do it a fucking again,
cause you know,
like I said,
you get that first ass whooping and uh,
and,
and a lot of times what happens is
it breaks and breaks out into fights,
you know.
And,
uh,
we,
we had,
we used to,
we used to bring the inner city kids into,
you know,
we had this idea what we're going to
bring in an inner city kids and you know,
in southeast back then it
was still very segregated.
So we are going to bring in blacks and
Hispanics and all these other kids and
bring them together and you know,
we're going to do all the fuck.
We used to bring these kids in man and
we started training them and stuff.
And then as soon as guys
would start sparring,
you know,
how many fucking situations we had were
guys would come back and with bats,
like there'd be a bad spar and deal come
back with bats or they'd come back with
their brothers or some kind of
just every fucking day there was.
So that whole,
you know,
let's bring in the inner city
kids and fucking tried to work.
It didn't go over well.
Yeah.
That's playing that experiment
and then work to us a lot of work.
It's interesting to see
the uh,
the attitude,
you know,
that used to exist back then,
the boxing gyms.
And now that people are,
we're,
we're seeing this evolution in mixed
martial arts where the beginning,
we saw a lot of like gym wars,
like that would be like a really normal
occurrence in gyms where guys would just
beat the fuck out of each other.
And you hear about Fido is getting
knocked out in the gym left and right and
left and right.
But now I think people are
starting to realize like,
Whoa,
whoa,
whoa.
There's no fucking benefit in this.
Like what's going on here?
But we're gonna,
we're looking at a gigantic multi,
multi,
multimillion dollar business and this is
how we're treating our commodities and
our prospects.
We're,
we're throwing them at each other
and let them blast each other.
And dudes getting punchy
way before their time.
And we both know Jim's work guys,
they get Chiney way too quick and you go,
well what?
How's this guy like?
This guy had an iron
changes three years ago.
Well,
it's taking fucking gym wars.
He's going through Jim
wars on a regular basis.
That was shoot the box.
That was the deal.
It,
shoot the box and shogun
himself said like we realized,
you know,
after doing that for a while
we can't do that anymore.
I know.
I that's how it wasn't boxing too though.
When I,
when I was involved in boxing some of the
best fights I ever saw her in the jet.
Oh yeah.
Oh hell yeah.
One day,
one day I saw uh,
uh,
Livingstone bramble and Roger Mayweather.
Oh fucking go at it.
Oh I had a fucking gym in Vegas.
Yeah.
Another time.
Why one of the gyms cause
cause we all worked together.
I worked with Mayweather,
I worked with Nick one kick,
um,
Floyd when Floyd was first coming.
I mean we all worked
together in these gyms,
you know.
And uh,
one time there was this dude,
he was a heavyweight,
his name is Tracy and him and Roger May,
whether fucking got into it,
he was,
Tracy was a young heavyweight,
24 year old kid,
heavyweight and Roger was fucking one 47.
Yeah,
in his forties.
She's like,
what you say mother fucker?
Just sit down at the fucking gate into it,
both the back and forth and go,
Oh shit.
Here we go.
And they got in the fucking
ring and start a fight,
man.
Yeah.
They started fucking fighting and at
the end of the round when the bell went
off,
Tracy tried to stop and Roger
fucking lit him up and he goes,
no rounds,
motherfucker,
no routes.
So they just kept fighting straight
fucking through until fucking Tracy quit.
Oh my God,
you're fucking whooped his
ass and he fucking quit.
And forties.
Yeah.
And then,
and then when he quit,
Roger hit him another eight,
nine times after he fucking quit.
And He,
and it was basically like,
don't have a fucking mouth off to me.
And this gym,
uh,
one 47 pound,
40 year old.
Yeah,
but Roger Mamba.
Yup.
You know,
a lot of people don't know Roger.
You know a lot of people,
everybody knows Floyd.
But Roger,
his uncle in his time,
he was a bad mother fucker.
He had a piston right hand.
Yep.
He had a nasty jab and he would
fucking slam that right hand in.
He was a bad dude
for many a year.
I've seen some crazy shit happen
in fucking gym boxing gyms,
man.
Crazy Shit,
huh?